en france pas de nouvelle information
concrète aujourd'hui sur la crise de la
listériose hier soir l'entreprise sa
part dont tous les produits avaient été
retirés du marché a été en quelque sorte
lavé de tout soupçon concernant cette
épidémie mail enquête a pu mettre en
évidence des conditions sanitaires est
insatisfaisante qui explique à
posteriori l'application stricte du
principe de précaution
alors comment le gouvernement français
gère-t-il cette crise unique en son
genre
éléments d'explication avec sophie
muscles lors de chaque nouvelle crise
alimentaire poulet à la dioxine vache
folle ou listeria trois ministères sont
concernés
le ministère de la santé sous son
autorité
l'institut de veille sanitaire lee vs
c'est lui qui en interrogeant les
personnes malades va remonter à la
source pour retrouver l'aliment
responsable de l'épidémie
le ministère de l'agriculture dont
dépend notamment une partie des
contrôles sur le terrain par le biais
des services sanitaires et enfin le
ministère de l'économie et des finances
et son secrétariat d'état à la
consommation qui a sous sa tutelle un
autre organisme de contrôle sur le
terrain la répression des fraudes
l'afssa l'agencé française de sécurité
sanitaire des aliments entité
indépendante qui évalue les risques
sanitaires dépend à la fois de la santé
de l'agriculture et de la consommation
trois ministères donc pour gérer de
façon parallèle la crise de nos
assiettes est un peu de cafouillage à la
clé en tout cas un problème de
concordance de la communication ainsi
mardi dernier de me jean louis jean
glavany faisait simultanément des
commandes et déclarations
contradictoires
recteur actuel l utilitaire pour
l'instant je suis pas en capacité de lui
dire simplement que c'est le produit qui
est responsable des vannes open 3
cas de listériose moi c'est pas
seulement pour donner
certaines produits
la marque le lot sinon c'est pour tous
les fabricants se produit là qui vont
être mises en cause alors que nous avons
et on comprend ce manque donc encore
dense car si chaque ministère est en
possession théoriquement des mêmes
informations leurs intérêts ne vont pas
toujours dans le même sens
comment en effet jean glavany peut-il
expliquer aux professionnels de
l'alimentation dont il est le ministre
la mise en danger de toute une filière
au nom du principe de précaution car ce
fameux principe de précaution président
aujourd'hui à chaque décision
depuis notamment l'histoire de la vache
folle est il applicable en toute
circonstance faut-il livré l'information
brute avant d'avoir le recul nécessaire
quand un risque et il ou non acceptable
le premier ministre avait annoncé en
octobre 99 l'organisation d'assises
nationales de l'alimentation la question
sera plus que jamais à l'ordre du jour